welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 has
released a ton of new footage ahead of
its release several promos and
featurettes even a full trailer tucked
into a Disney shareholder meeting I am
currently working on deep Dives of
Guardians volume 1 and volume 2 for the
Deep dive Channel coming later this
month and I found all kinds of new
Easter eggs discovering new insights
into James Gunn's plan for volume 3 so
I'm gonna break down all this new
footage for volume 3 including some
really really cool details and let's
start with the newest trailer clip from
this week called Greatest Hits after
some shots from the past films and past
trailers we get some new stuff here
I will destroy the Guardians It's Time
to Say Goodbye
Summer begins it's a Face-Off
all right new shots of the villain
Herbert Windham the high evolutionary
Marvel's Ultimate geneticist known for
experimenting on animals to create
Newman hybrids and it seems like rocket
was one of these Herbert's face looks
especially pulled back so who knows how
old this guy is but Peter says an
interesting Line it's gonna be a face
off which might be more of the guy's
Sports wordplay like what if this fight
ends with Peter Quill ripping windham's
face off of course Peter will wouldn't
have been on Earth to see John Woo's
1997 face off film but despite the
extreme violence of this move I could
see James Gunn making this reference in
an off-screen kill that makes everyone
on screen puke we also get some more
context about Herbert windham's Flying
Fortress as it rises out of waves on an
alien planet with a bridge much like
Tiamat rising out of Earth perhaps
Windham hid his Fortress beneath the
ground of counter Earth I do think
Windham has a connection to the
celestials and to Nowhere which is the
guardian's new home base and that wind
of maybe trying to replicate their
creation and World building process as
celestials have played a big role in all
of the Guardians films let's take a look
at the next clip I guess we'll die
trying
crew I know who you are already
according to the Galaxy Vol 3. are you
ready
I was eight years old when I left there
you want me to drive no I'll drive
figure out how to put it in backwards
yeah so I've spoken before about this
fleshy structure that the Guardians
float down onto and it seems like
they're gonna explore the inside of it a
facility with yellow liquid that flows
through it and guys in these bulky suits
my theories that we are looking at the
Flesh and spinal tissue of a massive
Celestial in Guardians volume 1 we saw
the skull of the celestial nowhere and
10 alertavon mind yellow spinal fluid
from that and I think the yellow liquid
in this facility is the same stuff we
see a few new Critters showing up in
this location a white furry fellow with
red eyes and spider legs and a big boy a
bear crossed with an octopus with
robotic appendages and Gamora slices
this guy open releasing yellow fluid I
think these are all creations of Herbert
Wyndham using Celestial fluid to endow
them with a higher form of sentience
which is why these creatures are able to
speak in humanoid-like languages so that
way Peter Quill mantis and Rocket would
all come from a Celestial bloodline
technically swole Groot might as well as
I've argued since his Flora colossi
photonic knowledge would come from a
photosynthesis process feeding off of
celestial light of those nearby him we
get a few cameos in here too one of the
workers is Nathan Fillion who came out
as a blue alien prisoner in volume one
and was gonna cameo in volume 2 on the
Missouri cinema Marquee as actor Simon
Williams but the character Simon
Williams is not gonna be played as a
superhero Wonder Man by Yaya Abdul
Mateen II in the MCU and then we see
Sylvester Stallone returning as stacar
ogord top leader of the ravagers but now
notice how his suit really lights up
here looking like his Starhawk form that
he takes in the comics when he merges
with his wife Elita ogord and the hawk
deity just kind of powers both of them
up like this now Elita o'gord was played
by Michelle yo in volume 2 and now that
Michelle yo showed up as a new character
in the MCU and shungji and you know she
won a freaking Oscar they might not
bring her back to this movie Just
suggests the two characters have merged
and got to keep sliced lone space Gamora
snaps back at Groot for repeating I am
Groot calling back Peter Quill initially
not understanding brute's language and
the Kiln in volume one I am Groot I know
who you are already
yeah you said that it's just so sad that
they've hit the reset button on Gamora
since this is a variant from Avengers
end game who doesn't have the history
with the others which means that she can
no longer understand the variances in
groot's words she was not there for we
are Groot I think that was the moment
they all started to really hear Groot in
what he was saying now if you're trying
to make a sandwich you can't go wrong
with cold turkey but if you're trying to
break a bad habit there are better
options like fume now there's nothing
wrong with habits it's just the bad
parts that need to be addressed instead
of a severe change why not just remove
the bad from your bad habit well fume is
an Innovative award-nominated device
that does just that instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
instead of vapor fume uses flavored Air
instead of harmful chemicals fume uses
all natural delicious flavors you get it
instead of bad fume is good it's a habit
that you are free to enjoy and makes for
placing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable flavor airflow
dial that is designed with movable parts
and magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and for anxiety while
breaking your habit using a fume is like
having a breath of fresh minty air
coming out of a world-class fidget toy
that looks like it came from a schmancy
gift shop stop being a bad habit is
something we all put off because it's
hard but switching to fume is easy
enjoyable and even fun fume has served
over 100 000 customers and has thousands
of success stories and there's no reason
that can't be you so join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tryfume.com
and use the code new rockstars to save
10 off when you get the journey pack
today that's
tryfum.com and use code new rockstars to
save an additional 10 off your order
today and we end with this hilarious
reminder that Peter Quill was only eight
when he left Earth and thus never
learned how to drive a car interesting
how the car seats have these beaded seat
covers maybe something to help the fur
covered animalistic drivers here and
counter Earth not really sure about that
let's move on to the trailer that was in
the Disney shareholder meeting hosted by
CEO Bob Iger here there is a quick shot
of the Zune on Peter Quill's hip on its
screen you can see the top menu artist
playlist songs genres and it's sorted by
decade 1950s 60s 70s 80s 90s 2000s but
not after that point because people
stopped using zoons after that this is
the Zune that used to belong to yondu
and replace the Sony Walkman that was
crushed by ego in volume 2. this was the
device that they played Cat Stevens
Father and Son over yondu's funeral and
it will play a very big deal in this
film especially now the volume 3
soundtrack has been revealed and it ends
with redbones come and get your love
which played over the opening credits of
the first movie interestingly rocket
seems to be holding the Zune in the Past
trailer and in the Funko figurine so
it's gonna be important to him a
close-up shows bulky fingers cranking up
some controls and a cockpit seat as
Rocket climbs into his looks like they
are piloting two smaller spacecraft
through a debris field this is not the
big new guardianship the Bowie but maybe
these could be Deployable craft that
detach from the larger ship of the Bowie
returning from Volume 2 Aisha The
Sovereign says these Guardians are more
powerful than you think she's in a gold
colored setting and a recent Empire
photo shows that her cocoon creation of
Adam Warlock is sitting right behind her
Drax throws one of these suited guys in
that facility I talked about which does
you'll notice happy High evolutionary on
all the screens and one shot Drax picks
up the guy and his head is covered but
Winnie Thompson said he no longer has
the head covering this might be Nathan
Fillion's character I'm not sure now we
get this crazy new shot a soul Groot but
just his head he's crab walking around
with smaller branches as his legs kinda
looking like that other creature we
talked about before but also the
crawling spider head form of the alien
shapeshifter and John Carpenter's The
Thing maybe Adam Warlock or someone
decapitated Groot in a brawl but Groot
survives the funniest thing about this
is just the music where we hear I'm out
of my head can't take it in the counter
Earth suburb Drax clotheslines a mouse
or a weasel person on a motorcycle while
mantis blows a pinwheel here's a quick
shot of rockets slurping some milky
looking fluid in front of a cooler that
has a Cree language written on it top
board is milky can't read the bottom one
yet Cracklin now has full command over
yondu's yaka arrow and whistles it to
take out these drones and nowhere seems
like cragland and Cosmo are going to be
anchored in nowhere which makes sense
Cosmo is really the chief of security of
nowhere in the comics and then we'll end
here with the April 5th face off Provo
sound corners of the universe consider
him God
face off
well I guess we'll die trying
I decided I try an a not thing no more
yeah I get back to this phrase of piss
off which is even the name of this promo
I think that face is literally going to
come off Gamora says Windham is
considered a God in many corners of the
Galaxy and I think all this really
supports the theory that Windham is
playing God assuming the role of the
creators of the cosmos of celestials
volume 3 really seems like the film that
will one up the eternals in the way that
it reframes the question of intelligent
design and speaking of which we finally
learned the species name of that new
Critter presumably another one of
windham's experiments blurp that's the
thing's name but gun confirmed its
species is a fasaki we actually already
saw a hairless masaki fighting an orloni
in the bar on nowhere in volume one
blurp is just a furry vasaki so again
next Friday April 21st will begin our
re-watch series of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 1 on the Deep dive Channel
with the Deep dive at Volume 2 coming
the following week so please subscribe
keep an eye out for those videos you're
going to love them and you can support
our growing Network by grabbing some
something from our merch store at
nerdrive.shop subscribe to new rockstars
on YouTube and on all social platforms
follow me at eavos thanks for watching
bye
[Music]